Now that we have the characterizations and
the knowledge representations the four concept's worked out,
let us see how the AI agent might actually use them. So let's look at the bowl.
Here was the knowledge representation of the characterization of the bowl.
The AI agent will abstract some knowledge from this particular example.
Here is its abstraction. Two things have happened here.
First, it is abstracting only those things, that are in fact causally related.
Simple features that have no causal relationship with other things, are not
important and they can be dropped. So we can add one other element of a notion
of an explanation. The explanation is a causal explanation. The AI agent is
trying to build a causal explanation that will connect the instance, the object,
into the cup. Second, the AI agent creates an abstraction of this
characterization of the bowl. And so in the bowl, it replaces it with an object.
So here the bowl carries liquids, because it is concave, and it is abstracted to
the object carries liquid because it is concave. This is the abstraction that is
going to play an important role in constructing the causal explanation.